Did you say infinity?
That's only a mathematical idea.
Yeah,
I mean how can anything be infinite?
I mean I know,
well there's a make mini math.
You can say it.
Like you can say that a straight line goes on forever and two parallel lines
will never intersect.
Pi Is there theoretically,
but you know it never ends well.
Why is that difficult to grasp though?
That's the real question.
Like why is,
why do we need everything to be defined by a very obvious beginning and an end?
Cause it's in everything we experienced has the beginning of that biologically
because we expand this time.
Time doesn't,
is not experienced everywhere the same way.
Well time is experienced at all.
If you're not sentient true Arizona,
they're whacking off.
It's different.
But yeah,
it's the,
I always wondered if like there was a reason why we wanted things to have a
beginning and an end.
Like is it because we have our life and our life has a beginning and an end all
the lives of the people we know or we definitely,
but you have to eat,
are obsessed with it.
We want to be the beginning or an end or are we terrified of beginnings and ends
thought too.
That's why we create,
you know,
God's and religions is because the idea that that life ends and that it's all
been for nothing.
It was terrifying to people.
There's a little bit of that.
Yeah.
There's a little bit of like doing it to create order in the community and
there's a little bit of people find mushrooms and they need an explanation to
fuck their feelings.
Brains are constructed in such a way that we need an end.
Yeah.
Or else you don't understand.
Why am I now I have,
there's no end.
My,
uh,
very uninformed theory,
which is that
first off that everything is meaningless but that only the brain damaged are
capable of conceiving of meaninglessness.
Cause our brains are meaning machines.
And that we evolved and it gave us an evolutionary advantage that we give
meaning to things.
Like I said,
this is a table because we say it's a table.
It's not a table to a cat.
That's why cat will just get up and walk around on it from a mutual agreement.
We agree this is a table and that kind of meaning let us organize our lives,
let us be better hunters.
Uh,
you know what?
You know it constantly,
it occurs to me and bothers me,
is that we decide not to drive into each other because we've painted a little
line on a road in the middle.
Yeah.
We've all agreed not to cross that line.
That's what I'm say.
We ascribe meaning to objects and that gave us an advantage over other animals.
And so our brains just evolved.
And then when we got to the point where we realized we're going to die,
we go,
well,
there's gotta be some meaning there too.
So then we had to create myths that where do we go created meeting about our
lives?
That's a very dangerous loop of there's no meaning to everything and nothing has
no mean nothing has meaning that that's a dangerous loop for a person
psychologically because you can get stuck in that and you can really,
but I don't think you can because it's impossible to,
of unless you are seriously brain damaged.
Well,
no,
I don't think it's impossible to conceive.
It's,
it's you won't,
you can imagine,
you can intellectually think about it,
but you can't,
you can't grasp it.
Really living in the now kind of the same as life has no meaning.
No.
Cause you're not often sing about the future.
You're not thinking about,
you're not thinking about the fact that it has no meaning.
You're enjoying life,
you're enjoying experience.
You're enjoying each interaction with people and enjoying your thoughts.
I think the,
the.